récession le mot qui fait frémir les
démocrates
les campagnes publicitaires
républicaines
car la réalité économique sur le terrain
fait mal
l'essence le panier d'épicerie les
loyers tout augmente ils se chauffeur de
taxi
à New York c'est la flambée des prix le
prix des loyers a augmenté de 35% en
moyenne au pays l'augmentation et de 14%
quant au prix de l'essence même si la
baissé depuis juin est recommence à
augmenter
on n'y arrive pas à dire ce chauffeur
ouvert je ne fais jamais le plein je
paye 5 à 10 dollars à chaque course
je dois travailler en dehors de la ville
dit-elle
je paye un prix de fou en essence
même avec un emploi temps plein ce n'est
plus assez
pour boucler les fins de mois
en moyenne le panier d'épicerie a
augmenté de 8% en un an aux États-Unis
c'est presque le double même en solde
le dernier sondage indique que 78% des
Américains trouvent la situation
économique lamentable 52% sont
insatisfaits du président Biden
les électeurs sont inquiets d'ici cette
politologue
sommes-nous en récession se demande-t-il
l'inflation préoccupe
les Américains doivent-ils se préparer à
une récession
tous les six mois les experts prédisent
une récession et ce n'est pas encore
arrivé si ça arrive elle sera légère
une possible récession avec comme toile
de fond accompagne électorale ce serait
de mauvaises augures pour les démocrates
qui pourraient perdre le contrôle du
Congrès les démocrates mis surtout sur
la question de l'avortement pour
remporter ses élections
sa campagne publicitaire attaque arrive
à la républicaine qui est
anti-avortement même en cas de
violetik quelqu'un qui a une victime de
la violation peut être enceinte amias
c'est arrivé à la républicaine
Martel le même message sur l'économie la
criminalité les migrants
seulement sur l'avortement pour gagner
ces élections
sont des enjeux majeurs qui ne peuvent
être ignorés d'ibolissendeuse pour les
démocrates la question de l'avortement
est majeure pour les républicains c'est
l'économie le 8 novembre les Américains
trancheront ici Radio-Canada Washington